¿Qué tenemos aquí?
Tenemos 3 elevado a la potencia "a",
y esto será igual a la raíz quinta de 3 al cuadrado.
Entonces debemos resolver este misterio.
¿Quién es "a"?
Ponle pausa al vídeo puedes intentarlo, observa que si... que si tienes una raíz quinta
algo que tal vez se te ocurra hacer para deshacer esta raíz quinta, es elevarlo a la quinta potencia.
Pero claro,
si elevas eso a la quinta potencia también debes,
debes elevar el otro lado de la ecuación
a la quinta potencia,
para que se mantenga la igualdad en la ecuación.
Entonces hagamos eso, vamos a elevar ambos miembros de la ecuación a la quinta potencia,
y el lado izquierdo de la de la ecuación....
Aquí debemos recordar las...
las propiedades de los exponentes.
Tenemos entonces que 3 elevado a la "a" potencia
y eso elevado a la quinta potencia,
es lo mismo que 3 a la "a", por 3 a la "a",
por 3 a la "a", por 3 a la "a", por 3 a la "a"...
Y ¿esto a qué es igual?
Esto será igual a 3 elevado
a la "a", más "a", más "a", más "a", más "a",
donde esto es igual a 3 elevado a la 5 por "a" potencia.
Así que la propiedad de los exponentes aquí,
nos dice que
si yo elevó una base a un exponente
y eso lo elevó a otro exponente,
es equivalente a elevar la base,
al exponente que es el producto
de estos 2 exponentes,
por lo tanto esto lo puedo escribir
de la siguiente manera,
3 elevado a la potencia 5 por "a"...
5 por "a"...
y esto será igual...
si yo tengo la raíz quinta
y la elevó a la quinta potencia,
solo te va a quedar lo que tienes en el radical,
entonces esto es igual a 3 al cuadrado
y ya queda un poco más claro esto
¿cierto?
Entonces 3 elevado a la 5 por "a" debe ser igual...
debe ser igual a 3 al cuadrado.
Otra manera de pensar en esto,
tenemos la misma base,
entonces este exponente debe ser igual a este exponente,
y así ya podemos escribir que 5 por "a",
debe ser igual a 2 y resolvemos esto.
Entonces podemos dividir
ambos lados de la ecuación entre 5
nos queda entonces que "a" es igual a 2/5,
2 sobre 5,
y este es un resultado interesante porque
lo lindo de este ejemplo, es que nos motiva
a ver cómo definimos los exponentes fraccionarios ¿cierto?
Así que vamos a sustituir esa "a" que acabamos
de encontrar, ya sabemos la respuesta.
Resolvimos para "a",
entonces tenemos 3 elevado a la 2/5...
lo cual voy a poner en color...
en colores para que quede un poco más interesante...
3 elevado a la potencia 2/5,
esto es igual...
esto es igual a la raíz quinta.
Ahora nota que la raíz quinta,
aquí el denominador es la raíz,
entonces es igual a la raíz quinta de 3 al cuadrado...
3 elevado al cuadrado.
Así que si tomas esta base, el 3,
y lo elevas al cuadrado,
pero después tomas la raíz quinta de eso,
eso es lo mismo que elevarlo a la potencia de 2/5.
Entonces nótalo, tomas este 3, lo elevas al cuadrado y tomas la raíz quinta de eso
o podríamos usar esta propiedad, esto
esto se puede escribir como...
como 3 al cuadrado,
esto es lo mismo que 3 al cuadrado
y eso lo elevas a la potencia 1/5...
esto elevado a la 1/5,
vimos esa propiedad acá arriba ¿cierto?
Puedes multiplicar estos 2 exponentes y obtienes 2/5,
y eso es lo mismo que 3 al cuadrado
y tomar la raíz quinta de eso,
acá también lo tenemos,
3 al cuadrado
y tomas la raíz quinta de eso.